hey this is presh talwalkar
alice and bob are on a game show
each is secretly told a whole positive
number
they are told the two numbers are
consecutive but neither knows the other
person's number
for example if alice is told 20 she does
not know if bob was told 19 or 21
and if bob is told 21 he does not know
if alice was told 20 or 22.
the point of the game is to guess the
other person's number
but there are rules to the game
alice and bob cannot communicate with
each other and they are not allowed to
plan a strategy either
the two are in a room where a clock
rings every minute
after the clock rings either player can
call out a guess of the other player's
number
or they can both stay silent
here's a clock that rings every minute
on the minute
the game continues until alice or bob
makes a guess
after the first guess is made the game
ends alice and bob win 1 million dollars
if the guess is correct and they lose
and get nothing if the guess is
incorrect
how can alice and bob best play this
game to win
each knows the other is perfect at
logical reasoning
can you figure it out give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the solution
at first it seems like alice and bob can
do no better than random chance
if alice is told 20 for instance there
is no way to know if bob has 19 or 21
but since alice can limit bob's number
to two possibilities she can at least
have a 50 chance of guessing correctly
bob has the same issue if he is told the
number n then he cannot be sure if alice
was told n minus one or n plus one
if bob guesses between the two
possibilities then he also has a fifty
percent chance of guessing correctly
acting individually alice and bob have a
fifty percent chance of guessing the
other person's number and winning the
game
remarkably they can do much better
there is a method they can win 100
percent of the time if they use logic
perfectly one key detail is the two are
given positive consecutive numbers
when alice gets a number n she usually
has to consider if bob has n minus one
or n plus one
but suppose alice gets one
bob could have zero or two
but zero is not a positive number
so bob must have two such a feelings
alice you know it to be two
a player that gets one will know the
other person has two
and since the player is sure the player
will guess on the very first ring of the
clock
they will win one million dollars for
sure
this was from alice's perspective but of
course if bob got one he would also
figure out that alice has two on the
first ring of the clock
but what about larger numbers we can
continue the logic suppose alice gets
two and the first ring of the clock
passes
bob could have one or three
but if bob had one he would have guessed
on the first ring of the clock
so bob does not guess after one ring
then bob must have three
alice realizes this after the first ring
and she will guess on the second ring of
the clock
in this way alice and bob will win 1
million dollars for sure
the logic would be similar if bob got 2
and the first ring of the clock passes
he would know that alice had three
so now what about larger numbers we can
continue the logic inductively
suppose alice gets n and the clock rings
n minus 1 times with no guess from bob
if bob had n minus 1 he would have
guessed on the n minus 1 ring of the
clock
so bob did not guess then bob must have
had the larger number n plus one
alice therefore guesses that bob has n
plus one after the clock rings exactly n
times
they will win the game for sure and get
one million dollars
bob would of course reason similarly
so in summary alice and bob can always
win the game
when they're given two numbers n and n
plus one
the person who gets the smaller number n
will always guess after the clock rings
exactly end times that the other player
has n plus one
this will be correct and they will
always win the game
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description